well I think like women  they are very difficult to satisfy which  is why  um what was it body count you said body  count which is why that's so important  so that they can connect to their  husband  um yeah I think that's it and I also  understand your point when you were  saying how they were sleeping with guys  that are like tens and nines when  they're like not because it just like  they want that but they can't attain it  um  yeah and that's why I think like a lot  of girls think they're settling but it's  just their level your level is what you  can get to commit to you  otherwise it's out of your league  yeah I mean it's a guy's levels who they  can get to sleep with them girls level  is who they can get to commit to them  if you can't get them to commit if he  doesn't want to be with you that's not  your level